you
you already dealt with word order when
we considered the syntax of romance noun
phrases like Elam a abhinaya and verb
phrases like to me Lu decays one easy
way to build longer phrases is to use
particles specifically conjunctions like
it and out or or mice but do it a go you
and I come to its crib oh I sing and I
write but there's more to full romance
sentences than this basic sentences have
a subject followed by a verb followed by
the verbs object
you wanna decay de la varita teh illu
mio amico d kt la varita that order
remains even if we substitute a pronoun
for the subject ela diggity la varita a
of course we've seen how these subjects
can and do just drop out sentences like
the get de la varita they occur in
vulgar latin and nearly all the romance
languages besides French romance and
their closest relatives the basic word
order changes when we substitute in
object pronouns la de que te la varita a
but la la' diecut or simply Allah diecut
the order here is subject an object
pronoun then the verb this also applies
to indirect objects and other small
unstressed clinic pronouns that cozy up
to the verb melody Kate
negative statements work like
affirmative ones and typically add a
negative particle known for not before
the verb nandi kit non-digital a very
Tata that known also comes before any of
the object pronouns Belen on melody kit
in French and romich the Latin negative
particle has become weaker and speakers
added a new negative reinforcer after
the verb to Yanis a bitch Jun CIPA these
languages along with oxygen can actually
delete the original particle before the
verb and keep their innovated negative
after the verb Shiva sabe bus for I
don't know other negative words like
never and nothing may follow the verb
this makes double negatives or even
triple negation a regular feature of
romance
Amod thing nada Ella no - nada en musica
nimi
literally she doesn't say nothing or she
doesn't say anything
questions can keep the structure of
affirmative sentences Aleida Kate de la
varita a lady Katie Lavery Tata
eliminated the subject may move after
the verb to signal that questions being
asked to dicuss elevated because to
elaborate at a ela decays to some
languages keep the basic word order but
may prompt the question with esta quad
literally is it that glow acid to say
okay - Louis a whiskey too thick
Sardinian has a question marking
particle ah and moves subjects after
verbs unfocused where question words
like the pronoun quit and the adverb
quando start with a quote in Latin
they're moved to the front of the
sentence in romance
whiticus give you give each n' choose
each all meaning what do you say
sometimes the subject is the one being
asked about we do get deliberately that
a if it's not the subject may still move
to the right of the verb do de que cela
very Tata quit decays to here you are
the subject and what is the object this
short introduction to basic romance
sentences gives us some momentum as we
push into more complicated statements
that's the topic for next time until
then keep your Latin vulgar